Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two
David P. two one nine two, David P.. Here
is a voicemail from a medical student
explaining where some of the
riffraff around ivermectin
is coming from. Let's take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, Dave. I'm a med student in
Arizona, and I just wanted to call and say that I
really loved your segment on ivermectin today. And
I also wanted to say that I think the ivermectin
thing is a little bit more complicated than people
are letting on. Obviously, ivermectin does not
work in humans for covid, but a lot of the people
to think that it does are citing a study that
looked at ivermectin in an in vitro way. So they
just took cells in the feature dish and injected
them with ivermectin. And low and behold, it
killed covid. But the dosage that is required to
do that is so incredibly high that in any person
to try to attain that level of ivermectin in their
blood, they would probably die or have severe side
effects. So that's why it doesn't work. So I think
that is just sad that no one actually realizes
that. So a great segment will appreciate everyone.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I appreciate the additional
information. You know, this is one of those
things where, like, if ivermectin really worked,
I would be saying this is fantastic guy. Like, I
don't I don't care. You know, before the entire
hydroxy chloroquine fiasco exploded about 10 days
before Trump came out and talked about Hydroxy,
I did a segment where I said, here are six
things we are looking at that are being studied,
which might have an effect on covid. And
I listed hydroxy chloroquine. Look, I. I
never had a problem. I don't know anyone on the
left who really has a problem. And there's this
conspiracy thing about the reason that they're
covering up that these things work is if there
is a good treatment for covid, then the vaccine
wouldn't qualify for emergency use authorization.
There's no evidence whatsoever that that's going
on. If ivermectin had an efficacy signal in a,
you know, a blinded with a placebo group,
randomized controlled trial, I would say we should
be looking at using that or hydroxy chloroquine or
whatever. But it's just not the case. And we can't
pretend that things are something that they are
not. We've got a great Bonas show for you today.
Unemployment benefits end today for millions
of Americans. We're going to talk about it.
Flu season is coming and it could be a pretty bad
flu season. I got my flu vaccine a couple of weeks
ago. I will tell you how it went. And there
are new plans for a 400 billion dollar city
in the desert which have been unveiled. Very
interesting. And we will talk about it all on
today's bonus show. Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom
and I will speak to you then in mere moments.